[crickets chirping]
[alarm blaring]
[panting]
[elevator descending]
[elevator dings]
[breathing heavily]
[low growling]
[screaming]
[Mike] Something is coming.
Something hungry for blood.
A shadow grows on the wall behind you,
swallowing you in darkness.
-It is almost here.
-What is it?
What if it's the Demogorgon?
Oh, Jesus, we're so screwed
if it's the Demogorgon.
It's not the Demogorgon.
An army of troglodytes
charge into the chamber!
-Troglodytes?
-Told ya. [chuckling]
-[snorts]
-[all chuckling]
[softly] Wait a minute.
Did you hear that?
That... that sound?
Boom... boom...
-[yells] Boom!
-[slams table]
That didn't come from the troglodytes.
No, that...
That came from something else.
-The Demogorgon!
-[all groaning]
-We're in deep shit.
-Will, your action!
-I don't know!
-Fireball him!
I'd have to roll a 13 or higher!
Too risky.
Cast a protection spell.
-Don't be a pussy. Fireball him!
-Cast Protection.
The Demogorgon is tired
of your silly human bickering!
It stomps towards you.
-Boom!
-Fireball him!
-Another stomp, boom!
-Cast Protection.
-He roars in anger!
-[all clamoring]
-Fireball!
-[die clattering]
-Oh, shit!
-[Lucas] Where'd it go?
[Lucas] Where is it?
[Will] I don't know!
-Is it a 13?
-[Will] I don't know!
[Lucas] Where is it?
[Dustin] Oh, my God!
[Karen] Mike!
[Dustin] Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
[Lucas] Can you find it yet?
[Will] No, I can't find it!
-Mike!
-[Dustin] Oh, my God! Oh, my God!
Mom, we're in the middle of a campaign!
You mean the end?
Fifteen after.
[Lucas] Oh, my God! Freaking idiot!
[Will] Why do we have to go?
-Mom, wait, just 20 more minutes!
-It's a school night, Michael.
I just put Holly to bed.
You can finish next weekend.
-But that'll ruin the flow!
-Michael--
I'm serious, Mom.
The campaign took two weeks to plan.
How was I supposed to know
it was gonna take ten hours?
You've been playing for ten hours?
-Dad, don't you think that 20 more--
-I think you should listen to your mother.
-[static crackling on TV]
-[grunts] Dang dumb piece of junk.
[Will] Oh, I got it!
-Does the seven count?
-It was a seven?
Did Mike see it?
Then it doesn't count.
[Dustin] Yo, hey, guys.
-Does anyone want this?
-[both] No.
[Nancy] Yeah.
No, I don't think...
Yeah, he's cute.
Barb, no, I don't think so.
-Barb, you're not--
-Hey, Nancy.
There's a slice left if you want it.
-Sausage and pepperoni!
-Hold on.
-There's something wrong with your sister.
-What are you talking about?
-She's got a stick up her butt.
-[Lucas] Yeah.
It's because she's been dating
that douchebag, Steve Harrington.
[Dustin] Yeah,
she's turning into a real jerk.
She's always been a real jerk.
Nuh-uh, she used to be cool.
Like that time she dressed up as an elf
for our Elder tree campaign.
[Mike] Four years ago!
[Dustin] Just saying.
[Lucas] Later.
-It was a seven.
-Huh?
The roll, it was a seven.
The Demogorgon, it got me.
[grunts] See you tomorrow.
[Lucas] Good night, ladies.
[Dustin] Kiss your mom 'night for me.
Race you back to my place?
Winner gets a comic.
-Any comic?
-Yeah.
[Dustin] Hey! Hey!
I didn't say "go"!
Get back here!
I'm gonna kill you!
[Will] I'll take your X-Men 134!
Son of a bitch.
[gasps]
[grunts]
[whimpers]
[indistinct growling]
[gasps]
[Will panting]
[dog barking]
Mom?
-Jonathan? Mom?
-[barking continues]
[indistinct screeching]
[line ringing]
-Hello? Hello?
-[static crackling]
[indistinct screeching]
[barking]
[whimpering]
[growling]
-[dial tone]
-[barking continues]
[panting]
[breathing shakily]
[growling]
[indistinct screeching]
[screeching intensifies]
[screeching stops]
[theme music playing]
[indistinct chatter on TV]